Invisible Code: Building JavaScript Libraries
For Non-Technical People
[Applause]
JOHN: So everybody in this room, it's probably
their domain to add new functionality to the
website but what about the majority of website
owners, what about that salon daughter who
has his daughter hack together a website for
him?
It starts off simple and then he has a script
tag added here, a widget, an image gallery,
a couple of analytics tracking tools for some
reason, so over time the small, simple website
turns into this multimegabyte monstrosity.
It's not really his fault.
He doesn't know exactly what he is doing,
he doesn't know the end result is going to
make his website cooler, so how can we as
developers of this third party embedded code
make this situation a little better?
Before we get started my name is John Fawcett,
I have been building out our AMP experience,
you may know Google AMP.
Also been helping out on our apps team so
I have been writing quite a bit of embedded
JavaScript lately and it has been fun.
So before we get started into the main thing,
let's take a look at some presumably reputable
survey, so according to Netcraft back in 2016
we hit over 1 billion unique host names and
that's Carl up there just for effect, right,
he has nothing to do with this and also I
added an emoji about an hour ago because everybody
else seems to have them, so a billion host
names, and 72% of these pages make more than
51 requests and we can imagine that seems
a little high and, of course, there is a bunch
that make way too many requests, right, so
the reason I'm showing you this is just to
give you perspective.
We are developers and we kind of know what
we are doing maybe, and the rest of the people
that maybe own the rest of the billion host
names on the Internet probably don't know
as much.
We should get inside their head, how are they
even adding this functionality to their website?
There's really three sort of scenarios they
go through.
They either know enough to be a little bit
dangerous.
They find a script tag on the Internet and
then just paste it into their site and then
tweet things until it works.
Then there's CMS plugins like Wix and Squarespace,
but maybe just ask a developer, or they copy
and paste as well, but we are going to focus
on these first two because at the end of the
day these are pretty much exactly the same.
Maybe in WordPress you have a few extra APIs
but these pretty much have the same constraints.
What are the constraints?
The first thing is environment.
This is a huge umbrella term, I know, but
when writing a web app we have a very well-defined
audience that we can actually develop for.
And for building embedded code we actually
have two different kinds of users.
We have the person that's going to be consuming
the code and pasting it on their website one
way or the other, and we have the end users,
and we can't make assumptions about what those
end users really are.
We want our code to be basically run everywhere
and that's pretty difficult, right?
So yeah, it's weird.
Next thing is file size.
We really need to respect the end user's bandwidth
and capacity to parse JavaScript.
We also need to respect the website owner
so these are no-brainer things but we really
have to keep them in mind when running or
making third party code to be embedded.
And browser compatibility, again if you can
define your audience you know, but we can't
really define that, it's their audience, so
browser compatibility is more about global
trends so you are going to have to support
older versions of IE than you want to.
And the user is an excuse for poor developer
ergonomics so they are creating a single JavaScript
that is hand-rolled to be ES5 compliant and
it's not maintainable, and it gets worse and
worse over time.
So network: you are likely being embedded
in a page where there's a ton of network requests
because they have three different analytics
libraries that are all tracking clicks and
the mouse movements, so something you need
to keep in mind is you may be trying to perform
a network request when there's a bunch of
other network requests going on, so maybe
we can do something, maybe we can check to
see how many network requests are going on
and try to push our pay load at a time when
it's less chatty.
So you are thinking you are going to write
a little widget for general consumption, maybe
an image gallery or anything, and let's just
- basic stuff, I know you guys know this.
You don't need fonts, okay?
Just use the host environment.
Fonts are crazy.
You don't need them.
No global rules; compress your images if you
have them.
Maybe even [sound problem] ... okay, back
to what we are talking about.
You may be asking: okay, we are going to write
some isolated DOM stuff and we are going to
style it.
The question is do I have an external sheet
or do I go with inline styles?
Okay.
It actually doesn't matter so much because
the problems you are going to run up against
are pretty much exactly the same.
You are being sane, you are prefixing your
styles, you are doing inline and then you
run across a global style, like this is going
to happen pretty much at least 20% of the
pages you are embedded on, somebody is overwriting
it dev style, okay, and you are like: okay,
maybe I can be very specific about my style
sheets and only - I will check for all these
things.
Then some reset comes along and has an important
tag, and you are like: oh!
Okay, what can we do about this.
What can we do about the global styles that
resets are putting important on, and one of
the things you can do is custom tags.
This works in IE9 and up and everything else
for the most part.
It's not compliant with the HTML5 spec but
it's one way to get style isolation.
In IE9 you need to create an element of the
name before you use it so here we have a custom
element called my widget and we have got style
isolation for the most part, so we solve that
and then somebody has got an all elements
select over and it's adding a border radius
to your newly designed and styled widget,
and you are like: okay, let's figure this
out.
So anyway, so we've got this and what do we
do about this situation?
There's one thing that we can do and it's
to use iframes.
That's the only way you are going to achieve
true style isolation and it's a good idea
to run your widget inside the iframe anyway
because it's a little more respectful of the
host's environment.
Yes, I guess we are having some interface
problems but I will go on.
So iframes, if you run a little bit of code
on the host environment that puts an iframe
on the page that's going to run maybe more
code in the background, some of that code
can be prioritised and not pretty much overtake
the page.
Let's find out what's going on with this slide
situation, and then I will continue.
This is the part of the talk where I say,
"How's everybody feeling?
Get up and take a stretch".
Well, you've maybe been seeing this crazy
scrolling thing, and there's like a bunch
of JavaScript CSS properties in there, so
what we can do with the iframe if we embed
it and we do this for some isolation is to
put the iframe in the DOM and then apply our
own defaults to it, and we take pretty much
every single CSS property and put it on that
iframe so we can have an expected behaviour
locally and on anybody else's page.
Of course, there's still edge cases but this
does cover some of them.
The iframe brings us to JavaScript, right,
we are creating the iframe and adding all
those CSS properties, so what are the pitfalls
and crazy stories?
Well, first off let's get the basics out of
the way - and keep flashing my slides.
Well, all right.
I could just turn my computer around and everybody
can come closer.
[Laughter]
>> It was flashing all of yesterday as well.
JOHN: Yes, I will just go through it, and
we will just deal with it.
So anyway, let's get the basics out of the
way.
There is some really simple stuff that I know
everybody knows: don't use globals, of course.
We've known this for a while.
Please, for the love of God, don't, don't
mess with the prototype, don't depend on a
library that messes with the prototype.
Minify your code.
Don't make a bunch of requests.
If you have something you need to phone home
with, create a route that you can batch request
to so you are only sending one, so if somebody
is on a mobile phone the biggest problem is
latency and if you are making a bunch of requests
phoning home just at least make a route that's
going to be able to accept multiple of those
requests, it's not too hard.
And of course profile your code.
The biggest problem I feel on a lot of these
sites is they've can included 47 jQuery plugins
and not all of them were very considerate
of performance.
If you are going to be having a copy and paste
script tag consider within the script tag
itself - I saw it and was, "Holy crap", this
is a great idea, and got a lot of feedback
from non-technical people, saying, "That's
all you have to do?"
Yes, that's all you have to do.
A little story about building the AMP viewer.
If you can imagine a block of code here and
then imagine a scenario I put myself in, we
will be in good shape here, so we are reason
the AMP viewer and the AMP viewer - actually,
how many people are familiar with AMP from
Google?
So you know when you search for Donald Trump
and you are wondering why I'm searching for
Donald Trump, and you go to the search results,
it has the little carousel - oh, look at that,
Cloudflare!
Hmm, that seems to be extending my desktop
now.
You want to check that out?
I guess it's in Preferences.
We can maybe move it over.
Let's check out Preferences.
Display.
There we go.
Perfect.
Okay, so I will go back talking about AMP
viewer real quick, so you click on a miniature
carousel in a search result, it has that little
lightning bolt and you instantly load the
page.
Google does this by pre-rendering the document
or pre-rendering the document they loaded
in an iframe in the background.
They've got it in a Google CDM and when you
click the article it flashes in the view and
tells the AMP document: hey, you are now visible,
you are now allowed to download images and
to download your analytics tracking tools
and actually start tracking so that's kind
of what the AMP viewer does.
So anyway, I had some similar code as this
and we had already deployed it to thousands
of sites, and we've started collecting data
and one of the pieces of data we collected
was that this list was undefined.
If you - you don't really have to understand
the code but the iterator function to the
enumeration methods like map and filter receive
three arguments, and the third is list.
It's the original list that you are iterating
on.
So why, in what scenario is list actually
undefined?
The answer is: when somebody overrides your
prototype with an implementation of map that
does not include list.
And who does this?
Well, prototype.js actually did it before
2012 and they realised their folly in 2012
and released a new version but there's still
a ton of websites that use pre-2012 prototype.js.
What do you even do about that?
How far do you go in not trusting JavaScript?
The answer is for us, you know, we went ahead
and fixed it and said: okay, let's not rely
on that variable because there's too many
people that are relying on Prototype.js, pre-2012
I might add.
So it's up to you.
You really need to be collecting that data
though, that's the important part.
How do you do it?
Well, we used Sentry.
If you haven't used Sentry, it's really awesome,
okay?
I'm just going to zoom in here.
I mean, you get all kinds of great information,
you get the browser and all, the device and
the breakdown of browser and the errors that
are occurring and you will see here the stack
trace comes in, and we are running completely
uglified code and yet when the error comes
in we can actually see the line that had the
error and you see this is a TypeScript file
which we will talk about a little bit later
in developer ergonomics, so yes, we have TypeScript
or we have Sentry error reporting.
Now, we only run this for a sample of our
users so not everybody is going to be reporting
errors to us, and it's a pretty easy thing
to do.
You just say: hey, script actually report
errors to Sentry; or don't report errors to
Sentry.
So that's another thing about being a little
bit responsible.
You don't want every single one of your pieces
of code phoning home for whatever reason,
but there's a problem.
If you've ever used Sentry you know there's
a line called Raven.js which is a sort of
embedded library of sorts as well and they
follow the pattern of a massive JavaScript
file that is about 2400 lines of code at the
end of the day and it's 24 kilobytes minified
and you have to wonder how many SHR wrappers
there are on any given website so Raven.js
is great, it does a lot of stuff for you,
but it was too much for us.
So what we did is we already had our own SHR
wrapper, we already had the ability to parse
stack traces.
We just used the API, right?
If we have access to the API, we can go ahead
and push all that error information and we
don't have that insane amount of code in our
build.
What this really looks like is you are just
hooking into the on air function on window
and you can't use at event listener, Air,
I've already tried, but you can override this
function and hopes nobody else does as well.
You also need to check that the file name
coming through is actually your file because
there's going to be a ton of errors on the
page and you don't want to be reporting them
all to your Sentry incidents.
So how do you get rid of those SHR wrappers
and one of the things we came up with is API
fingerprinting.
We live in a world where jQuery of us this
dominant library and still is, even though
we rarely use it anymore as developers in
this room, so - well, let's just look.
According to some survey 89.5% of their top
websites use jQuery and then estimates for
the entire Internet is just under 20% so you
have a very high likelihood that $.AJAX exists
already.
So we should start building little abstractions
that make it look like Fetch exists for everybody,
even if they don't have Fetch and maybe they
have jQuery, and yes, it's a pretty good chance
had a they do have jQuery.
What if they don't?
Object query?
Try something else.
These are really cheap and then you have a
really nice interface.
So what if this embedded code is still running
and relying on the Fetch API?
You need to download it.
Or you could say this code is not going to
work and I'm going to error out and you are
like: oh, I have a 80% likelihood that my
code will work.
No, we can do better.
We can actually just dynamically fetch polyfill
or jQuery even because maybe they have it
cached.
A problem: we are seeing if some code exists
and then if it doesn't we have some asynchronous
step that must occur and in reality we would
want an interface that just works.
You pull in a module statistically from your
bundle and you say: get me this resource and
you want to be able to just check the body,
right?
You want this.
But in a situation where dependencies may
not have even been loaded yet, we need to
queue up these requests and once the dependencies
are satisfied and the API has been defined,
then we can go ahead and resume those requests
but to a developer it should feel just like
this.
So we created a little library.
It's essentially dependency injection, right,
but it's a little bit different.
So we just had these little decorators and
of course the decorators are a little bit
of fluff, they are not that much code to add
in, but you could use the non-decorator API
just as well.
So we let these functions though that we need
the fetch API and whatever the fetch API that
will be defined by us, and we also want to
let it know that any call to these functions
should be queued up until the fetch API actually
exists and has been resolved.
So what does defining the fetch API look like
for this?
The first thing, the same little library we
build, we are going to pull in a definer option
where we set up the dependencies, let it know
what they mean.
We pull in some strategies from the other
part of the library and we only pull in the
things that we are actually looking for because
our module bundler is going to do some tree
shaking, right, and we are going to have as
little code as possible so we pull in these
different strategies and then we go ahead
and define what Fetch would be and it's just
a chain of these strategies.
We are going to look for the built in global
fetch, then look for jQueries and wrap it,
then build an external resource, wait for
it to load and then apply the jQuery strategy.
I say jQuery because probably others are cached
just from their travels.
That takes care of that.
Let's keep our bundle size down.
Performance tips: I can't really say a whole
lot - many have already said, and maybe Jason,
but we will go over a little bit of stuff.
The main thing we found is we don't want to
negatively affect performance on the page
and we don't want necessarily the best performance
but we should probably queue our expensive
actions so with the AMP viewer for a lot of
our customers there is this discovery step,
right?
And we are going to take all the links on
the page and then check an external service
to see if any of those links are AMP.
And then we are going to modify the DOM with
little icons that say: this is an AMP link.
If you click on it, it's going to be really
fast.
And that's an expensive operation because
we are calling up to a service and then modifying
the DOM so what can we do about that?
The thing we came up with to non-effect performance
on initial load is a measure of FPS and you
can do that by using request animation and
counting the frames.
So the measure XHR is not super-reliable and
I'm not even going to talk about it.
Some expensive operation just needs to be
put on a queue and be deferred until later
and we can go ahead and just tell it: hey,
when the FPS is at least 30, then maybe it's
a safe time to go ahead and do this.
We will probably want to wait until other
libraries have done their thing and this will
probably work.
So developer ergonomics, earlier I said a
lot of these embedded JavaScript libraries,
they sacrifice a lot of the modern development
practices that we've learned over the past
few years in favour of creating a very small,
tight, single JavaScript file, and I'm arguing
that that will result in crappier code that
will not be maintained properly, so just think
about it.
So for AMP viewer reading TypeScript as I
said before, it's really great, it produces
fairly small type code that's ES5 compliant
and we have a really great developer experience
from it.
So what does the AMP viewer do?
This is what I was explaining before.
A little BMW cable, that's not going to work.
That is cool.
Let's try to go back and see if it does it.
Whatever, you guys know what I was talking
about.
It handles push state history API, it has
got very smooth animations and we are actually
using a library called Preact and Jason Miller
is giving a talk right now about it and it's
a 3.5 version of React so it works really
well, we've got it on thousands of websites
right now and some of the builds are under
15 kilobytes which to me still seems too much.
3.5 of those kilobytes is Preact.
I am pretty sure we can get this down, all
the components, everything, and once I figure
out how to properly mangle all my props using
Closure Compiler I think we will be in a pretty
good state.
So anyway, like I said, we've got this really
beautiful component-based architecture using
TypeScript so everything is checked statically
at compile time and we didn't really have
to sacrifice the code in order to have a small
file size.
Also, you know, module bundlers these days
roll up in webpack, they can export things
to globals and just use function closures
so you are having really tight code that is
just wrapped by functions rather than something
like browser - little header file or a little
header part that helps load the module at
run time so you don't have a whole lot of
overhead and you can also export to multiple
targets, right?
The general consumption target is going to
be to global.
Something they are going to copy and paste
that needs to self-register under the page
is going to be text supported, right?
But so many times I have downloaded or tried
to use an analytics tool and they say the
way to install this is you copy and paste
this chunk of minified onto your page, and
I end up copying and pasting that into its
own little module so it's all in my bundle,
right?
So it's so easy to just have a different target
for your developers.
You have an ES6 target and you say in your
package data: here is my ES next entry point
and here is my main entry point, my widget.
It's really easy to do so use rollup or webpack
please and also export to global for the non-techies.
So we've kind of gone all over the place and
I hope that you maybe learned a little bit
from my travels.
So please responsibly code and maybe try out
the fingerprinting API.
That should be open source pretty soon.
And queue your expensive operations because,
yes, it's good for the world.
So thanks.
[Applause]